she disappear for 20 day for my birthday
and my grandma did
I feel bad and feel alone and this woman
come here for my life and sex and find
out how you feel it and talk
maybe two weeks later this woman again
text her no it was three months later
and you had been telling her the same
time I'm not sure Jamie did you cheat on
Chris twice
while Chris thought you were in a
relationship three times only one
the two times the third time she
befriended her on her Instagram after I
had moved to Colombia and this chick's
you know liking all of her photos and
and responding to her photos and she's
like I didn't know she was on there
you know when somebody's responding and
liking your pictures on Instagram
so she's admitting to cheating ones I
want to know from Jamie why did Jamie
cheat because she disappeared in time
as this is normal
Chris Jamie keeps saying that you
disappeared for 20 days no it was fun
for one month no it was five days for
one month one month she disappeared okay
was it five days or was it a month
there's a big difference it was five
days no
I see in this relationship between Chris
and Jamie there is a giver and there is
a taker Chris is the giver Jamie is the
taker and I know it's very easy to
manipulate someone that's suffered
because they're looking for acceptance
and love and it's very easy for a
predator
to take advantage of Chris are you
calling Jamie a predator yes oh wow what
okay
I don't agree I don't agree either
[Music]